what was it like for you to see the film
this one yes I haven't you know because
I was working on daddy's home to when we
were doing all the ADR stuff
right and Michael normally that's when
he would show me the film um because
he's so secretive he wouldn't send any
the footage to Boston so all the stuff
that I did I did via satellite actually
did over the phone having some listened
to the sound and then dubbed my voice
he's like I tell you what happens in the
movie yes no I know what happens you
know probably 2,000 times I have scripts
how was it working with him on set
easily I saw him i watch him for a few
hours and he's almost perfect on set how
was it with working for you it's been a
few times now right ah you know what
he's got this whole movie in his head
yeah and you know we're all there to
service his vision and just got to make
sure that you know we're ready to do
anything at any time and Isabella who's
in this she's got a lot of spunk and
there's a few kids in the film yes did
he ever come to you and say hey do you
want to cast one of your kids in my big
movies no he wanted to put my kids in
the first transformers that I did a
distinction and basically by the time
they got to the set some of them got
cold feet they ended up doing the scene
right but um it's one of those blink and
you'll miss some type of moments but
this time around they just they love to
watch the transform of movies but then
all I be making them because they're so
long they're so long and your birthday
just has happy belated birthday 33 now I
guess right ah 46.8 City was pretty
close it begs the question what kind of
cake did you have I didn't have any cake
on my birthday I don't think he had cake
for his birthday
but I was in Rome yeah so we definitely
had some sort of dessert we did the food
there it's funny because I've been to
Rome many times I'd always like to
promote movies and now I'm shooting and
moving there and the food something
happened where the food has just become
so amazing and if it's just because now
I'm going to the right restaurants but
then you start even eating the desserts
and I'm like I'm eating pizza and pasta
my oh this is going to destroy my
stomach because I have very sensitive
stomach but nothing I'm good then I'm
like eating these ice creams and it's
something about the bread they make a
difference how does it all avenges know
who added as preservatives everything
fresh organic visits Vatican this time
around I did I got a special tour from
the Swiss Guard I actually got to a
place with a Swiss Guard had never been
yeah it's called the room of tears where
they actually go after the Pope has been
elected they take him into this room and
dressed him before they send him out
onto the terrace to be presented and the
Swiss Guard was like any one of the top
guys was like thank you likewise I could
have never been in that room okay well I
was like Munich Pope then uh I've
actually met the Pope in Philadelphia
when I hosted the festival offend me
Holy Father has a very special
individual he's a cool guy Marie yes now
did you get a chance to actually touch
the cars did Michael Bay let you near
any of them if I had to drive them and
then I could then I could touch them
it's not they are to keep somewhere just
to be yeah so if you were in the car
what song do you like to cruise to uh it
depends that the kids are in the car or
not or or if it's your minivan yeah yeah
it depends I usually just flip the radio
stations but the kids are all like they
want to listen to their stations of a
favorite song right now yeah not really
anything by Bieber Justin Bieber our boy
I'm killing it